Hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Connerz. This is episode four of my personal journey with cancer and I hope it is going to be an encouragement to you when walking through the last couple episodes of things that I am currently doing. Now that's going to change over time.
My life is going to change over time and doing multiple these episodes over the last few days because I played catch up a little bit. It's been a big struggle for me to share my personal testimony.
And again, I apologize, but I don't apologize. It's who God made me and God had to really work on me to get to a point to share with the world and my patients and whoever is going to watch these my majority because I'm a very personal person that I don't like to be out there like that.
I like to be out there as far as telling you know information that I learned. I love to teach and if I could live my life over again, I'd love to be a high school teacher and a high school coach at basketball and football because I love to teach and share my knowledge that God has given me.
But I don't like to talk about me very much. Maybe I do too much. I don't know, but I don't want to. So this is my struggle.
This is another piece of nutrition that I just started using a few weeks ago. I will share a video of this.
Outside of my jury, but I'm really excited about this because of a couple things. I've known for my first started working with cancer patients.
The benefits of aloe barma, I think it's pronounced, I think it may be pronounced that incorrectly, but the type of aloe that is so good for cancer patients.
The problem with it is that it's very unstable.
And there is currently one other company that makes it a liquid form that I'll tell my knowledge about this product. I felt that product was the most stable.
So the history goes back, and I don't remember the names of everybody, but there was this missionary Jesuit missionary priest in Brazil.
I can't remember his name, but the story goes that he was healing people with cancer with this aloe barba decent plant that he was using.
And he was giving him live aloe, breaking off the leaves. And they were eating the aloe right off of the leaves. And they were seeing these remarkable turnarones with all sorts of diseases and cancer was a major one that he was helping people with.
Well, when that when when people heard about that and nutritional companies heard about that, they started to make aloe products capitalizing aloe making liquid aloe products to be a health benefit to possible cancer patients or other health patients.
And the problem with it is that it had extreme limitations and just didn't see the same results. It was not any miraculous results with it.
And then oh, about a decade or so, maybe 20 years, 15 years ago, it was found out because the benefits of the aloe is that it's so high in polysaccharides.
Polysaccharides are multiple saccharides, which saccharide is a sugar. So it's multiple sugars linked together with a with a carbon bond, and there may be 100 or more polysaccharides that are linked together.
And I'll talk more about this when I just do a video just on the polysaccharides in evolve immune, but it's the polysaccharides that are so great at stimulating ones immune system. That's why mushrooms are so good.
So the mushrooms mushrooms are so beneficial for you because of the polysaccharides.
So there, there's a lot of talk about. Should we use chagas? Should we use Coriolis? Should we use myataki? Should we use Rishi mushrooms? Well, all those mushrooms that I just named are really good because they're all really high in polysaccharides.
Whereas your common button mushrooms that you'd buy in the store to grill up and cook over your steak, very low in polysaccharides, really not a medicinal value in button mushrooms.
I don't know what the species name is, but it is the Rishi of the myataki and the turkey tailor, the Coriolis versa color that are that are high in polysaccharides and so beneficial. That's why we have our mushroom blend.
And mushrooms again, too far off subject need to be if they have the highest polysaccharides, they're going to be organic, but they're going to be grown on a live tree, not grown on rice panties.
In a room somewhere, but live tree mushroom grown, that's why I've been taking chaga.
I'll talk about that in an next episode, but I told you on the last episode that I've been taking our mushroom makes what has multiple mushrooms in there and has other things in there to like marine good things that are so beneficial also.
But that's why I am so big on mushrooms. It's one of my five faves for cancer patients, I guess, is mushrooms because it tests out so well for people.
Now, I've always known that the alobarbidescence is even higher in polysaccharides, but the problem is it's unstable, it's completely unstable.
So if you dry it and capitalize it, the polysaccharide coat drops tremendously.
And so the benefits of it were difficult. Now, there were a few years ago, tell a little backstory. There was another company that we used.
It was it's we still use a lot of their products for very research lab. And I think their products are great in the order of the company is no longer with us, but he was really evil about the quality of the product.
That's why I really like their products and really loved it when he was with us. And he was instrumental in bringing actually a process so that they could they could bottle the aloe right in the field.
So they went to I think where he was getting it was Italy, I'm not really positive where they were getting it.
But they were they had a process that they were actually bottling it right in the field and sealing it. So I think at that time it was the most stable form of the aloe.
And we were using it. But then something happened with the quality or the ability to get it or the, you know, it's so hard when you're dealing with trying to get good product.
You can have a bad season and the plants don't grow real well. And your supply drops to nothing and that it's really hard to keep people happy.
So that dried up and they don't carry that product anymore. They just couldn't keep the quality up so they don't it's just they just don't have it anymore.
And then I found out about this company and this company actually purchased the pattern from a little lab in Texas. I believe the story goes that this, this, this laboratory patented away to stabilize the aloe barbedessence.
In a form in a dried form so the polysaccharides stay stable. And so there's only one company. There's only one company that holds the pattern. I think they share the product with another company and it even gets the story.
It's the story even gets better because they have the pattern to have stabilized polysaccharides. And then they also patent away to pre digest them. But that gets into a little bit more detail that I'll share of the video about this product itself.
But they're searching size in polysaccharides are not measured in number of saccharides in the chain. They're measured in weight and it's measured by the unit adult.
So it's measured in number of Dalton's of weight. So they it was found it was discovered that the really the immune stimulant polysaccharide value is between 50 and 400 Dalton's in weight.
So most of the polysaccharides in aloe or in mushrooms vary from zero to, you know, several thousand Dalton's weight. Well, the ones that weigh a thousand Dalton really don't stimulate your immune system.
If we could pre digest the polysaccharides so we have a greater amount of them between 50 and 400 Dalton's we're going to have a greater amount of immune stimulation.
And this company right here this evolved company is the only company that owns the pattern to pre digest stabilized aloe so that there's a greater amount.
There's five four five six seven times the immune stimulation per capsule in this product than any other product on the market.
So it's just a really superior product and so I started taking this I read a book about it that actually my cousin gave me who is in this company.
I started taking this product and I noticed because I was really felt like in all honesty, I was going downhill, kind of a rapid slay it about two months ago.
And I just really prayed about okay, Lauren, I just got you just got to tell me what to do and my cousin is in this company and understand I have my mother was from 15 kids I am 88 first cousins on my mom's side literally 88 first cousins and honestly I hate to say this, but I don't know them very well.
So I would be good as a kid to remember all my kids names I'm going to remember all my cousins names so it's I kind of pushed him off he called me tried to contact me a couple of months ago.
And then he contacted me again about a month ago and I just felt like the Lord said you need to talk to him.
So I try to listen to the Holy Spirit communicating to me and I'll be the first to admit that.
I don't always do that very well. So at this time I just felt that dodgy to the Holy Spirit I said okay, I got to meet with him and I ended up meeting with the owner of the company which this guy's probably worth, you know, tens of millions of dollars at least.
And he came to my office and met with me spent 45 minutes with me. We had a wonderful conversation.
We could relate in a lot of terms I understand the physiology of it and I understand the benefits of polysaccharides because mushrooms have been my favorite for a long time and I really sought out an aloe product, but I had no idea before he came over that they even had this product.
So looking at how the Lord works.
So I started taking this currently I take about eight of these a day.
It's not a super inexpensive product.
And I don't think I'm going to need to take eight a day in the rest of my life, but I really have noticed an uptick in how I've been feeling.
And that is that's not the only reason you know share that in another episode some things that I've changed that really noticed an uptick, but this has been a real blessing for me.
So that's episode four next episode I'm going to share about some enzymes have been doing that are really fun and interesting, but I think have really helped me a lot.
So thank you very much and we will talk again very soon.